okay so i think we should start because
the numbers have stabilized and this
will give you more time and more time
for us to listen to your talk so hi
everyone uh i'm shafi goldwasser i'm the
director of the simons institute
and uh for the theory of computing
and as you
may know the simon institute was
established in 2012 by a very generous
gift from the science foundation
and uh
it's my really very great pleasure to
welcome you to a new seminar series uh
the speaker today is the second speaker
in the series called the breakthroughs
lecture series which highlights
substantial
advances in the field of theoretical
computer science
and
we look forward to this talk and for
convening the series in person in calvin
labs starting this fall right now we're
still in the zoo mode although we have a
quantum cluster that's going on at uh
simon's in person right now
um
what else would i'd like to say um
something about the q a so people should
free to feel free to post questions
in the q a link
at the top at the bottom of your zoom
page and
at appropriate times we will refer to
them and the speaker will answer them
our speaker today the main feature and
the most important part is yuan si chen
and yuanzi is an assistant professor in
the department of statistical science at
duke university and previously was a
postdoc fellow at eth
um and in 2019 he obtained his
phd from berkeley
um the department of statistics and
advised by bennu so
in fact uh yuanzi told me what is
berkeley time which i um
forgot
since we've been so
for so long out of the loop uh in doing
things in a standard way
and he graduated before that from the
core political clinic in france in
applied mathematics and his main
interests are statistical machine
learning
mcmc sampling optimization domain
implementation and statistical
challenges that arise in the
computational science and probably much
more and today uh his talk is entitled
an almost constant lower bound of the
isoparametric coefficient in the kls
conjecture
and instead of me explaining uh what the
result is and what the history is i
think that we are going to benefit much
more
from yancey himself telling us the
background for this conjecture and what
he's shown and we
are extremely uh excited that you were
willing to give us this talk
and want to hear about your breakthrough
so please uh take the stage i'm going to
mute myself
and you should unmute yourself
okay
okay uh thank you jeffy for the nice
introduction yeah thank you everyone for
coming to my talk
uh it's uh it's a great honor for me to
talk and
give a talk at the same thing
actually during my
six years at
[Music]
uc berkeley for a phd assignment
institute has always been
a great source of uh
inspiration and a great place actually
to spare an afternoon
yeah
it's been great so it's great honor and
now i can
give a talk here so today i'm going to
talk about the
almost uh
constant lower bond
of the isothermatic refreshing the krs
conjecture so krs conjecture
dates back to 1995 and it's an important
conjecture and theoretical computer
science and i will explain
so
i will divide this part into four parts
i'll first explain a little bit in the
history
and related problem to the
uh kos conjunctions well kos actually is
named after three uh authors canon loves
and simon novich
and this has uh
many important implications in
early computer science and statistics
um and then in second part i will
explain the high level ideas actually in
the
original proof of the kos paper 1995
where you they introduced a technique
called localization lama technique
and then in the third part i will
introduce i will introduce this
uh eldon stogas localis scheme is
actually a technique we use actually in
our paper to get
the current best
uh lower bound of hydro-parametric
coefficient in the kos conjecture so
um
this this technique was invented in like
2013 and then in the class part i will
explain the progress in our paper so uh
yeah so the the the lecture series
titled breakthrough but for me i think
that the real breakthrough already
happened when eldon introduced this very
like fancy and very
sophisticated proof technique in 2013
and
yeah so i will make sure that actually
we get a good compress uh comparison
understanding of the the second and the
third part and so
the first part might get a little bit
technical but yeah we'll try
okay
so let's say the qrs conjecture
chaos conjecture is a conjecture about
the isoparametric coefficient of
log concave densities so let's say let's
define these things so what is the
isoparametric coefficient
so first you need a density or a
condensed body so that then for convex
body then the density is a uniform
distribution over the convex body for
example this
polygon here
uh polytope here are
and then the either premature
coefficient
is the infimum over all
partitions of this uh
density like this space into two parts s
and s complement
and this
boundary measure divided by
one part of the measure the minimum of
the minimum one power measure so the
boundary measure is
is the limit like you think about
you have
cut the space into two parts
and then take the uh you have this mid
width in the middle and then
you let the epsilon 10 to 10 to zero and
you get this boundary measure so you
want to compute
um how large is boundary measure
compared to this two parts so what does
it mean
somehow means that it somehow
characterize the width of this this this
convex body or this density right so
imagine if you have a sphere then um
like
most cuts with the ps equals to one half
they they will have a very large
boundary measure right so this is good
uh have large electromagnetic
coefficient but if you have
certain objects with
a bottleneck or with a long shape that
that either pretty much equation might
be smaller so let's explain
let's um through some examples
so
so people study hyper premature
coefficient in other fields as well not
just in public
um
in statistics so
here basically uh
why are so i was always wrong so this is
actually a physics problem of course but
you can try to have a model this problem
is uh
isothermistic problem so you want to
find
basically a surface such that
uh
such that uh the idle primitive
coefficient which is a minimum over all
kinds of
uh
surfaces such that uh the
either permit that adventure is achieved
right so you can say that actually you
can prove that actually if the
underlying density is like a uniform
distribution over a convex set in 3d
then the sphere is one that actually
achieved as a premature coefficient so
that
uh
minimize the
the the surface area over the volume
with a fixed volume here over the volume
of this
and then
yeah so
with physics you can kind of
um you you can kind of say that oh this
this bubble has to be run so because it
wants to minimize this kind of quantity
minimize this energy um
and then yeah so either parameter
coefficients so typically you can
imagine that if you have a convex set
like like a round shape set
no matter how you cut the space
yeah you will have a pretty large
boundary right and but if you have this
kind of sets with the bottleneck
uh this is like a sunglass kind of shape
uh set
and then if you cut
here
uh the boundary measure will be very
small but the ps and s complement they
are about to be one half right in this
sense that you can make this thing is
bottleneck as small as possible and then
you can make this uh hydroparametric
quotation very small
okay
so that's some intuition about this
either permission coefficient and now
like let's define this the log concave
density so chaos conjecture
does not try to characterize the
aggregation coefficient for every set so
only deal with stop-and-go density
hopefully this locomotive property
actually gives you
some
good properties like good uh bound for
the idle parametric coefficients so
a probability density is not concave if
it satisfy this inequality
basically
uh when you take the log of this density
it is concave uh the your concavity
formula
so you have
exponential logistics density they're
locked on k because the
intensity is proportional to e to the
minus f with f convex function
and
the uniform distribution over convex
that is actually a large class of
shallow concave densities
um
it's proportional to indicator of k
so actually so if you take the log of
this density some parts will be zero so
that's why the logan kept definition is
written in this without taking the log
we want to include this uniform
distribution over convex set and
and this will be like our main running
examples actually uh throughout the top
so detail now let's state the chaos
conjecture the pls conjecture states
that
for any low concave density
you uh
you you can bond it's a primitive
position
by a universal constancy divided by some
normalization constant so you here you
you need some normalization constant
because imagine if you
have a density that is very elongated in
one direction and very thin in in in
everything uh
uh
uh
in in in like it's like the those uh the
shape have shown
like yeah and
or or not not sunglasses but uh
long kind of a long line kind of shape
and then even if it's like a convex body
it's low concave then it's um
this idle parameter coefficient can be
very small if you make this very long
right
and so here the normalization is
basically saying that
if you constrain
the covariance of the density to be
a fixed
matrix a
and then you divide by the square root
of the spectral norm of this a
that's the normalization in the
but there's actually a simplification
that people usually do that
uh in the isotropic form meaning that we
only deal with the ideotropic law
concludes identities which is mean zero
and variance identity so then this chaos
conjecture is stated as
uh that the idol premature coefficient
of all log concave densities
is uh lower bounded by c or isotropic
logan conveniently
c is a universal constant
so we can actually prove an upper bound
of the same form
and actually tell us show that
in 1995 that
half spaces so if you only make the cuts
which are half spaces
and you can
show that actually the
then then yeah then gives the upper
bound for this either parametric
coefficient right then you can show that
actually there's a this is a constant so
it's upper bounded by a constant
um
so the difficult part is uh is like
whether we can prove
this
is a lower bond
so yeah so also since the upper bound is
achieved by
cons half spaces like constant you can
also think about the normalization that
is happening
in the kos conjecture
is the based on the normalization for
half spaces so it's like if i constrain
myself to all the half spaces what will
be the normalization median and that is
that is this quantity
okay so the kos convector is famous
because it's related to
several other conjectures
uh so the
kind of most visual kind of conjecture
is this uh singular conjecture
it tells you about like how concentrated
or how uh how what where are the mass of
isotropic flow concave densities so
um
antilla black ball and the terry synergy
in 2003 they stayed in this conjecture
as
uh for any hydrotropic long concave
density
um
there exists a universal constant
so sorry there exists a neural
concentration that for any local cape
has a traffic lock density
the things show constant is upper
bounded by c what is intro constant so
the essential constant is
basically the average
deviation
of the norm of
x
around square of d
so you have you draw your
random variable according to density p
so the mass is
centered around
is saying that the mass is basically a
wrong square of d
and
the square root b is basically
the
square root of the
the trace of the variance right in the
in the idotropic case
uh
and the width is of order constant
and
yeah so the master super constant is is
concentrated in this in this sense is
around this
sphere of square of d
okay so um
so it is actually not hard to prove that
if you only deal with the standard long
concave density around uh sorry standard
gaussian density rather than uh
arbitrary isotropic low concave density
uh you can show that this
concentrates around this
sphere square radius square d and
with the other constant and it's kind of
saying that for other block concave
densities
as long as it has identity covariance
matrix this this type of concentration
probabilities is similar
um so the essential conjecture is
actually
shown to be equivalent to kls
conjunction up to log factors so
um
one direction the keras enticing shield
that is kind of the easy part uh sugar's
inequality but the other direction
is not cheerio it was shown
by erdogan in 2013 so it's uh
the same this where they he invented
this stogastic localization landmark he
also showed that the sensual conjecture
in high skills congratulations
um
so here basically yeah so here
um
we when we talk about this like we want
a universal constant but
uh
we're we're not there yet like yes we
the
the research is basically try to get
these constants as small as possible in
terms of dimension d dependency
okay so there's also much earlier
conjecture it's famous conjecture called
sizing conjecture
it's
introduced by burgundy
it says that there exists a universal
constant c
such that for any uniform distribution
over convex set
there exists a hyperplane section
which uh kind of which is quite large
the world is very large volume
which is kind of intuitive right
you have convex sets
and the convex set by definition it
cannot have this kind of bottleneck
shape everywhere so you have to find
some direction
uh that the the section is large
right um
but actually it's actually
intuitive but
when it's stated in this form it's very
difficult you to deal with this
conjecture
um so in 1988
paul actually stated that an equivalent
statement of the slicing conjecture
that is such
exists a universal constancy such that
for any ideotropic location density p
we have this slicing constant is upper
bounded by a universal constant on this
universal constancy the cycling constant
for isotropic logical density
is in a quite simple form let's just
look at the density at point zero and
take the power one over d
okay
so y is actually this
so this actually this this lighting
constant is also related to this kind of
concentration high dimensional
concentration properties so here is a
theorem actually
uh if you have a slicing constant you
can get a very good high dimensional
concentration probabilities for all
uh isotropic low concave densities
so
the theorem
office 2006
says uh
um
steady aviation
uh so that the of this uh square root of
the the norm of the random vector
jump from the isotropic log concave
density
it will have a sub exponential tail
and the place where it starts to have
this type of exponential tail is roughly
basically the slicing constant times
square of b so if the starting
conjecture is true basically it's saying
that from this square of the radius you
have this this type of self-exponential
tail well if you cannot yeah if this
sliding constant is offer other square d
then this quantity is slightly worse
right so you want this kind of thing to
be able to prove this thing uh very
close to constant so
so that this performs basically
uh like
like exponential kind of
density or yeah
okay so the chaos conjecture implies the
other two conjectures you can show that
up to
the factors we are ignored
oh actually here and not even yet it's
actually quite constant factors you can
show these three inequalities
and the first one is basically showing
the
uh inverse
inverse of the algorithm as a parametric
constant in the chaos conjecture is
larger than the singular constant and if
this is can be shown in uh by triggers
inequality it also summarized in uh
neilman paper in 2009
and then the singular constant is larger
than the slicing constant this is
actually shown i have done and attack in
2011.
um
so yeah if we show that the kos
conjecture that this is a constant then
we can also show its initial conjecture
and size in conjecture
um that's why i actually put the title
only focusing on the chaos conjecture
well it's not actually the
the oldest the conjecture the slicing
conjecture is oh this one
um
okay so
here i'm going to talk about a little
bit uh relation to the mcm sampling
theory can't explain my past going there
i
i'm not actually a convex geometric step
by training but i kind of study
in mcmc sampling problems that
arise in statistics i try to understand
uh their mixing time of the convergence
of those
sampling algorithms
and it is usually uh the isotomistic
coefficient is usually a key quantity
that arises
in when you try to prove mixing time of
sampling algorithms and typically yeah
it comes like in one over uh guys for
chocolate at the parameter coefficient
constant square this type of
so you kind of care about this addox
temperature coefficient and if you want
to establish a theory for sampling over
all logarithm distributions then you
care about the kos constant
and also yeah
um
in some situations this has weird
implications like
if the chaos conductor is true
in the problem like some problems i
study in high dimension the uniform
sampling on polytopes
it kind of implies there's no need to
design very softly sticky sampling
organisms in some settings so let me
explain a little bit in more details
um
so we have this problem of like
uh sampling from polytope uniform
sampling from polytopes so the polytope
is just defined by a linear equation ax
s and b here is a polytope with five
constraints and dimension two then this
matrix a is just five times times two
and
you try to solve uh so so yeah people
care about this type of sampling
problems because you don't you are not
satisfied with optimization problem like
you want to diversify your solution or
um
uh there are
cases where you actually
the
you want to compute the volume of the
polytope and then the sampling algorithm
becomes uh
useful
and the simplest algorithm in this type
of setting
for sampling from convex set is called
the bulwark
so it means that it each iteration
the proposal distribution of the
sampling algorithm is just a ball and
then based on whether the point is
uh it's a uniform distribution of a ball
and depending on whether this point is
inside the polytechnic or central book
you you either accept or you reject and
then you work
with those small balls and walk around
this polytope so this type of algorithm
has a mixing timer this square over
uh isoparametric coefficient square
if the polytope is in isotropic position
meaning that we normalize it to mean
zero and variance identity
so this is actually a good bond um
together with the iteration cost you can
see the the computational cost is
basically md to the cube over the either
parametric coefficient square so if we
can prove this algorithm
coefficient is of order constant we get
a d cube
m
kind of uh
mixed mixing time bond
in terms of iteration costs so at the
iteration you check whether this linear
equation is satisfied and that's exactly
but then there's also like a lot of
people develop a lot of like
sophisticated random work
where at each iteration you not only
just check this
linear equations but you also kind of
want to adapt
to the local geometry of the polytope
meaning that each step says
the proposal distribution is no longer a
ball but uh some ellipsoids for example
in liquid work
and then uh intuitively if you have kind
of weird shapes that polytope like
elongating one direction those
adaptive kind of proposal distributions
will be better
and
so they are better so in terms of making
time you can prove that it does not have
this uh as a parametric coefficient
dependency you can prove that some of
the sufficient work like john work is
offered these square but their
projection cost
is no longer
this
md but actually slightly larger because
you kind of want need to invert a linear
system of course if you if you listen to
the
previous um
uh
um
breakthrough talk you yeah you might say
that eventually maybe this this will get
to
m times d rather than m times the omega
like minus one which is
the same as
forward in some situations like if the
matrix multiplication or major's
inversion theory gets better but
currently there's a gap in here so
currently it means that if the
polyphobia is in isotopic position
and if you can prove the ks conjecture
and then just means the bulwark is
already very good it's it's it's you
don't need to go to very sophisticated
uh sampling algorithms indicates uh
where uh
this uh
dimension is
is large but this number of constraints
is much larger than the damage and then
you can see that is sorry it means that
in some high dimensional geometry inside
this high-dimensional polytopes
you don't really need to adapt to the
local geometry of the polytope those
those bars you you walk by those forces
it's enough gives you very fast mixing
um so this is something kind of very
intriguing for me of course this problem
is not complete stuff is still open that
uh
what's the minimum like dimension
dependency you can get
and people are conjecture that is around
like the the mixing time should be
around b if you but this is these
algorithms are still quite far from d
um
okay
so then
yeah i'll talk about the previous
progress on the kos conjecture and then
i'll talk about the the the proof
techniques so
um
so you can derive the ks under a bond by
essential conjecture like we mentioned
uh
it is via like eldans paper in 2013 that
if you can get a singular constant you
can get a lower bound on the other
parametric coefficient in the kos
conjuncture so uh
so actually this uh this um this
progress in essential conjecture
uh has it is it's very active yeah
people get this dimension dependency in
essential constant that goes from e to
the one half to d to the one third in
2011 in uh get on middleman paper and
this
type of proofs usually
uh
are consistent actually are basically
some kind of projection
and
projection of some high dimensional
density and then show some symmetric
property of the
projected density and it's very kind of
geometric kind of
proofs
um
so there are also people directly attack
the kls conjecture so in the kls 1995
paper actually introduced this
localization gamma
that
shows that the inverse isoparametric
coefficient is now further
due to the one house
and then in 2017
and liam and paula used the stochastic
localization lemma idea from
eldon and prove that
this dimension dependency is due to the
one force
and in the 2010 paper we have uh the
dimension dependency becomes d to the
log log b over b to the one half so
this exponent goes to zero and b tends
to infinity
so um in a large d regime if we ignore
all the constants
that is the typical setting in the
territorial community sense but if we
want to ignore all the constants then
this this is better than any d to the r
file with alpha constant
done so that's why we called it uh
almost constant lower bond um so here's
the
timeline yeah so in the 1995 you get e
to the one half and then using those uh
conjecture bonds you get
uh to the d to the one third and then
star basically local addition so the
stochastic revolution was invented
around here
and we get b to the one force
and then we get e to the
small of one it's log d over log law
love log of the overlapping
okay
so uh so in the next i will introduce
basically the localization lama so the
localization number and the cigar signal
of application lemma they share word uh
localization so i'll kind of explain
what is localization in this literature
and how the main idea works
so
localization number is basically this
number it looks complicated but let me
explain so you start with the
two high dimensional integrals
and there's two functions g and h they
are semi-continuous so they're
continuous
in a lot of places but it's allowed to
have some jumps
um
so if these two semi-continuous
integrals are positive
in the localization number science says
that you can find a one-dimensional
integral
uh
one-dimensional find function l so that
the one-dimensional integral
is still positive
so basically uh
bill the idea is dealing with high
dimensional
uh integrals high dimensional
inequalities is difficult
but if i can find a one-dimensional
integral uh that deal with
one-dimensional inequalities that might
be easier
okay so this is called needle
decomposition because this actually this
this is also called needle dimpling
because this this thing this l you can
think about this some kind of
area of infant infinite decimal cone
that you are integrating your gnh over
and it's called a like look like a
needle and this needle decomposition
idea actually goes back to
panel ember in 1960 when they were
trying to prove some fungi and equality
and this is actually
uh
uh this a concrete kind of dilemma just
to to to actually to rewrite this this
idea and specific for
this uh
kos conjecture type setting so
how do we use this localization lemma
let's try to prove a simpler
isoparametric inequality which is
the diameter isogrammatic inequality
so
in the diameter in other parameters in
poly inequality
uh you
want to prove that for any partition s2
s3 s1 s3 of the space
the the middle part
is larger than the minimum of the
two parts
around it
with this coefficient is the distance
ds1 s2 divided by the diameter
so if you take the limit when s1 is 1 2
close to zero then this one over d is
basically the agrochromatic
coefficient right um
here so this this type of
um isoparametric unif uh coefficient you
can relate it back to the kos conjecture
because uh if you assume that uh
density is either isotropic meaning that
the coherence is identity then the
effect diameter is of order square d
then you basically prove that
the the kos conjecture with the
hydrochloric equation uh
one over square root of b right which is
uh okay bound but it's not uh yeah the
the best one we can get so let's explain
actually how
actually they use that the localization
that much to get this bound
um
so uh the proof is by contradiction so
this high dimensional
uh
inequality you want to prove you cannot
assume the converse so meaning that
there exists some partition so that this
is not satisfied
and then
you will define two functions g and h
which is in
which are the two integrals that start
with in the
localization level based on these two
inequalities we get from the uh
conjugation like that the converse we
assume okay so they define this as g and
so this is g and this is h
basically then you have like two
you have
sorry
you have two
uh integrals that integrates to positive
value
and then
you apply the localization number
meaning that you can find a needle so
that
these two integrals in the one middle
direction they are all positive
and then basically you can partition the
needle
based on
how the high dimensional space is
partitioned you get z1 z2 and z3
and then you get a one-dimensional
inequality
from
the the
the high-dimensional integral inequality
right and this one-dimensional inquiry
inequality is basically a form of
one-dimensional isoparametric inequality
and because you can show that this this
this transformed density is also low
concavity of this if g is cloud concave
and then
one dimensional concave the
isoparametry in quality for log concave
density is very easy to prove or not not
that easy but you can prove it it's
harder it's much easier to deal with one
dimension than high dimensional and then
you will reach some kind of
contradiction for certain gamma so
that's how you prove
a high dimensional hydropharma diameter
either formation inequality you use the
localization number
to change the problem
to
a one-dimensional
isoparametric inequality and you prove
the one-dimensional permission quality
and then you relate back to the
high-dimensional case then to get at the
premature constant
okay
um
so this idea will appear appear again
actually in
in a later part but before we do that we
we kind of we want to
give some proof sketch of this
localization number how how it works it
looks like a fancy
lemna right this you have two high
dimensional integral and you get you get
a needle that is one dimensional
integral how to get that to that needle
the idea is that is to play like three
ninja with density this is kind of
a kind of uh a mobile game like this
back to long but it's actually a term
quantity by
uh ron and eldon uh in
around 2013
and the idea is to to cut basically to
cut the densities in some way
um
so you have used that we start with two
high dimensional integrals uh integral g
and integral h they are both positive
and then the first step is to find
a bisecting half plane capital h
so that
it will divide the integral of g
and then since it divides the
um
since the integral of small h is
positive
then either the left left part or the
right part of this hyperplane a half
space h has to be positive so we take
that part as positive so what you have
done after
you have done this uh obviously you you
did this is that you basically
reduced
our
integral that is on the entire rd space
to
uh
half space and you get two integrals
that are both positive on half space
right
um
so you can repeatedly doing this
actually as long as the kind of the
effective dimension of that space
is is small is larger than two and y is
larger than two i'll explain it but we
can repeat that many times and there you
need some kind of smart
ways to say that you you do this time in
a countable number of so you knew this
procedure in a contemporary number of
steps and you can take the limit and you
end up with a needle so why is like you
can only do up to dimension two is this
the way they find it by setting half
space
is because
it's not an uh arbitrary half space but
it's also not a wheel as like does not
have very explicit form so you have an
integral of g that is positive how do
you find a
a half space that divides it so you will
start with some random half space
and then
you fix some point and then you kind of
rotate this half space
and when you rotate this half space
to net 360 degree
the the integral on one side of half
space on the left side of that space has
gone through from positive number to
negative number
right so it has to go through zero so
you this is the implicit way basically
you find this half space
but when
diseases have to be always exist if your
effect dimension is kind of large but
when
you basically
only have a one dimensional need or you
cannot do this kind of
rotating and find this kind of hard
space so that's why
you end up with needle not just
something else or higher dimension or
some higher lower dimension
thing um okay so this is kind of this
localization
the the good thing the advantage of this
localization emma is that it easily
proves this the diameter other
parametric inequality
we have seen that because
that
your high dimensional integral
the high dimensional problem
no matter how you basically no matter
how you
find that needle the diameter is the
constant it's an invariant quantity
throughout this
this localization ml procedure right so
the low dimensional inequality with the
diameter e
so the high dimensional equality
requires dimension the uh diameter d the
low dimensional
problem also have diameter d so you can
kind of get back
uh from low dimension result to high
dimensional result okay the same thing
happens if you want to prove either
parametric coefficient for alpha
strongly low concave densities alpha
strongly local meaning that
it is it can be written as the form e to
the minus f with f is
surely convex functions and so you mean
that the density has some kind of
curvature and
in this case it's easy to prove by a
localization lemma because uh if you
start with a
functional concave density you cut this
space and one dimensional needle will
always be
uh operationally low concave and then
the one-dimensional inequality can be
related back to the high-dimensional
inequality but in general it's
it's it's done does not quite work to
prove that uh kos conjecture because the
chaos conjectures in the normalization
factor
is actually about
the variance of the density and the
covariance of the density and the high
dimensional
covariance of density is identity we
wish the one one dimensional
uh needle also has their variance there
one but actually in general you cannot
prove this you don't have much control
when you do this
like throw ninja or like this cutting
the needle might be lying in the very
long direction of mine might be lying in
a very short direction
and um
the needle might be as long as like of
other square would be rather than a
further one so then you will not get a
uh a constant uh
at the parametric constitution in the qs
conjecture and yeah yeah let me
let us reflect a little bit on the high
level strategies basically
you want to prove a high dimensional
adder parameter inequality of this form
but you end up proving a one-dimensional
parametric coefficient inequality which
is much easier to deal with
but the the video is like you need this
one dimensional inequality this this
camera you can relate back to the high
dimensional
ones right so in the localization level
there's many things there the
signs of these two integrals are kept
cons
kept invariant in this thing but the
other proteins there's something you
kept
invariant but you also want like
uh you'll be able to relate the
one-dimensional inequality to the
high-dimensional inequalities and in the
chaos conductor case you you do want to
control the density the variance of the
density
when you do this
procedure of like
like messaging or changing the high
dimensional density to a low dimensional
density um but actually in the current
in the in the localization number you
don't have much control
okay so
that's now let's introduce the eldans to
basically variation lemma which is
actually the proof technique we use to
to get our uh current
uh results
so the question erdogan has faced with
this basically
uh is it possible to have a better punch
of the cuts when you play this uh
floo ninja basically you
is it possible to cut the densities in a
better way
um
rather than this uh
this localization level we have seen
that you have to rotate something and
you don't have at least control of how
you rotate the half spaces and cut the
densities
so yeah he has many attempts like this
are some
slight extremely seamlessly copied from
his slides in early stage around 2013
he
his first attempt was trying to
control the cuts with random class
rather than this rotating and stop at
some arbitrary point
you just introduce those random cuts
and here it means that you start with
some density uniform
distribution over this convex step k
you get a random direction you kept it
you get
k1
and then you get you can get another cut
random and you get k2
and you want to reduce
a high dimensional either parametric
inequality that is on k
to
the high dimensional
the the the the lower dimensional
hydrophobic change quality that is on k1
k2 and k
like many steps right so the good thing
in this procedure is that the volume
ratio
is fixed so if you start with some
arbitrary initial set of size
one half this volume ratio of s over
sk is always concentrated around one
half that is a good property this volume
of
s is fixed so but then
what you also want to control is that
the the the idle parameter coefficient
right you want the ido parametric
coefficient is also conserved then you
can prove it but actually in this
procedure we don't know or it's hard to
get this as a parametric contribution
controlled or it's hard to get basically
the variance of the density control that
you you have those random cuts but these
random cuts
will end up somewhere but it's hard to
uh to to bond this uh
or the
the
the the variance of those
uh their densities you end up with
um
so then he comes with a second up
attempting controlling the cuts so
instead of
like truncating the half spaces
with a big knife or like
chopping the half spaces they just
multiply these
densities with small random linear
functions so you transform the
densities in a small in a smooth way
and
so here say like f0 is a uniform
distribution over k so i try to use some
color to highlight the density change
the the dial column instantly increase
the light color density decrease so you
find one direction
uh you multiply by 1 plus epsilon x
transpose theta like so then on this
side on the right side of this
hyperplane
the density has increased a little bit
on the other side decrease a little bit
so you can do this
again with uh like uh several random
cuts the second random cut in this
direction then this side increases
depress depresses so you can see that if
you take epsilon to be small this is
like a smoother transformation of the
density than the
the previous kind of
approach
and
some properties about it is it
it actually no longer keeps the density
rich the volume ratio between
s and k so in idle parametric inequality
you try to prove
ps is larger than some constant over the
p boundary of s is larger than constant
times of p s
and p s complement but then this
ratio does not constant you need other
ways to
to control this uh hydropharmagic
quality but this epsilon actually
is handy because you can make estrogen
10 to 0 and then it becomes a continuous
procedure and you have
like we will see that it has many you
have other ways many ways to deal with
this continuous procedure and then also
because we multiply by a small linear
function it will make up here a gaussian
part in the density
so
you can see that if you happen to
multiply this two linear function with
opposite directions x1 and minus x1 and
this is approximately 1 minus epsilon
square x1 squared this is possibly
exponential function square x1 squared
it means that actually
you multiply your density
by a minus epsilon square x1 squared
which is actually adding some kind of
curvature gaussian part to your density
so that leads to
uh it's the
actual stochastic like localization uh
formulation so stochastic localization
is actually a stochastic
differential equation that characterize
uh a transformation of the log concave
density p
to p t so you can see that the pt
um
when yeah what so in this stochastic
differential equation case basically you
already let epsilon 10 to zero
and you have
a brand new motion change
and and in in the intercept term
and
you have some gift term and then on
on the
on the quadratic term term it's it's
calculated by some control matrix ct for
now i assume just its identity
so um
in the quadratic term you just basically
increase
you multiply by a more and more stronger
and stronger uh gaussian term but the
intercept term is interesting you have a
brand new motion term here
and with this
exclusive form of the transformation of
the density pt you can show that it's
actually related to the elder's second
attempt
you can show that a pt is a martingale
and it satisfy this property for for any
x so you fix your fixed x the density at
point x
is just the density multiplied
by
one plus
the linear function and the
random direction here the data is
changed to this dwt this uh running
motion part
and so this is basically the seriously
differential equation characterize the
transformation of the density and then
we can
uh
yeah sorry i
actually don't have time to to this but
actually it's starting with some uniform
distribution uh you can do simulation to
show that actually eventually so you
transform the density smoothly and
eventually it will come up
there will be a gaussian part that come
up dominates industry but how do you use
this logarithmic localization
technique to prove an algorithmic
inequality so what you want to prove is
this boundary measure
is larger than a minimum of psps
complement with some isoparametric
coefficient here right here we restrict
us to subsets of measure one half
because uh
i result and
in the middleman 2009 you can restrict
yourself it's enough to show that either
parametric coefficient uh the difference
is always a 10 by subset of measure one
half is enough to show it this
then
you can see that
the way they are proving it um
is to by transforming the density so by
marking the property the density at time
t
the the boundary measure is the same as
the original
boundary measure this is marginal
property and this is the transform
density for the transform density since
you added some gaussian part to it it
will have a
isoparametric inequality or the measured
coefficient and so it's like for
strongly low concave
is which has a gaussian part in it
it will have the isoparametric
coefficient of order
that it depends on the covariance matrix
that is that is added
um
the quadratic part that is added and
then for this transformed
density you want to relate back to the
original density and if you can show
that actually the the
the volume
of pts remains between one quarter and
three quarter
that then you can basically this is one
this is one half one half and
if you can control this probability then
the final ideoparametric coefficient you
get is basically um the amount of
gaussian you add it to your density and
then this probability like you can
control this pt so the problem now
becomes an analytic problem it's no
longer a geometric problem you want to
start you want to study this stogastic
differential equation that is
characterized
by
this type of static differential
equation
and then you want to control bt and the
pts
and
let me briefly talk about how to control
this bt and pts
um
so the bt if you choose the ct control
matrix to be identity so the bt just
linearly increased which is
can i distribute a second so we are at
56 maybe
wrap up in a minute and then we ask
people if they have questions
yes yeah i tried to finish this part
yeah this intuition part
so yeah so um
the dt is kind of easy
to control if you take the control
measures to the identity
but uh
the the control of the volume of pts
a you can take the derivative and look
at how to bond it you can see it depends
on the spectral norm of the at80 is the
coherence matrix of the density at time
t
and then the whole problem boils down to
control
the spectral norm of
80
so that controlling the covariance
matrix the spectral norm of the
covariance matrix at time t
and yeah so you take the derivative and
to approach the spectral norm people use
the
potential function
you raise to the power q and then take
r1 over q
so liam and paula use the
the power q equals two and ct equals
time delta t to show their bond and
basically
they get a stochastic differential
equation and you solve it you can
control these two parts the
d to the minus one quarter is the
gaussian part you add
and then you can control this part
of other one and then they get this uh
lower bound of the hydro perimeter
coefficient in the kos conjecture and so
what we did in one minute
um
we basically
like the nature extension you take
larger power in the potential function
and larger power means that you get more
precise
are you closer to the actual spectral
norm you want to control but there are
some difficult terms
when you take derivative of this term
and you can summarize actually our proof
is basically
trying to actually control this
potential function like this completely
differential equation in two stages
which is not like in previously they
only control this potential in in one
stage and
we get this type of bootstrap results
meaning that if you have some
kos bond of order 1 over
e to the beta you get 1 over d to the
beta minus beta over hq and this allows
you to boost up this lemma many times
and you get
a lot of this log vectors
um
okay so i
don't have time to explain this part but
um
yeah so
some takeaways you have to deal with
this log computer densities are from
last bodies in research basically the
the improvement of the kos conjecture
allows to improve the essential
conjecture and also the
the constant in the bar who is lemma so
those concentration equalities
are improved and also
um
the localization lemma and elder studios
energy drama for me they are kind of
very powerful
proof technique of also beautiful proof
technique to reduce the high dimensional
geometry problem to actually
analytic problems and gives you some
handle to deal with uh
high dimensional geometric problems and
what's next so
our result is not a complete resolution
of the kos conjecture uh you may need
other proof techniques to actually reach
a universal constant bond in the chaos
conjecture and
yeah so the way we don't know actually
we have reached the full potential of
the stochastic relations scheme
and um there this recently there are
some starting to have some other
applications of
erdogan's stochastic localities scheming
other high-dimensional phenomena and
that is also interesting and let me end
this short thank you
thank you so much for this uh
you know fascinating talk and i'd like
to see if we have
like no minutes but is there some
question that's burning question i don't
see questions in the q a but i know
among the panelists somebody already
asked if you could extend the talk by 20
minutes
because they wanted to hear more detail
so is there uh
one question or two that um are you a
panelist or uh independent would like to
ask
um sure i had a question so um
going forward to get a constant factor
uh kls conjecture
is it that the
the stochastic localization technique is
not good enough as in
if you run an experiment and look at
those
one-dimensional sections it produces
it's not they're not concentrated enough
or it's just that they can't bound the
uh
boundary quantities in order
yeah that's that's a very good question
uh actually you can show that even for
very simple uh convex bodies if you just
apply ldn service localization you will
at least have a log effector but yeah
love deflector
is good actually you know our bond the
current bond is actually worse than log
defector it's due to the
level of the overlooked field is is
worse than a love defector but
so the evidence focuses localization
will lead you to a log factor but even
that we
we cannot reach it because we don't have
a full understanding of that stupid
differential equation so maybe there's
need additional understanding but uh um
on yeah if you want but if you want to
go beyond this log effector then you
might
other techniques we would say yeah or
you can use a big modification of this
how does the casio collaboration scheme
thanks thank you anybody else
then i
if not uh then i think that uh
okay here is a question
uh by a deal does it have any
implication on the constant in the
telegram inequality
sorry sorry guys
it's intelligent inequality
yeah yeah
all right
would you like to
respond to this question
i i don't i don't know exactly which
paragraph and quality we talked about
yeah which call and he's actually
wondering that too
yeah
sorry about that yeah
okay so uh i think that at this point
we're gonna thank you again
for uh a very very instructive talk and
uh lenny tells so well um
you know also what has led up to a
result and including and i think that
there's some people who want you to
continue talking but i think they're
gonna have to reach you offline and uh
again i'm very grateful that you joined
us and and you've given us this
breakthrough talk
and uh
thank you i appreciate it very much and
hope to see you in person in the fall in
one way thank you yeah thank you for the
questions i'm sorry i just yeah went a
little bit
uh out of time but sorry about that yeah
it looks like you have a lot more to say
also thank you very much bye
thank you bye